[Music]
okay hey everyone we're really excited
to have you guys next I'm holy Maya's
product manager on drive platform and
I'm Steve basil a developer programs
engineer 4gb api's and we ate today to
talk about something at every
enterprises facing you'll always be
growing your wings getting new people up
in productive new team members need to
get access to all the existing files and
when people leave you want all the work
to disappear the fast and smooth at you
can achieve this the faster you get
employees up and productive and that's
why we created teen drives teen drives
extends drive with safe easy to manage
shared spaces for teens and starting
today teen drives is supported by the
Google Drive API we have a couple of our
partners here today to talk about what
they're doing with that API to help
teams work better together indentified
and large organizations the need for
drive and drive apps have evolved of the
last year's most work is done in groups
when drive and the drive API were
originally designed the vision was on
the single user sharing files on a
one-off basis all the file ownership
permissions and engineering
optimizations were centered on this one
use case so the result you could get
into the confusing states when you're
collaborating on files such as the same
as different people having different
views on the same folder for example I
shared the presentation full of his
Steve add some files in there for him
but I didn't realize those files is more
restrictive emissions than the folder
itself so Steve never even saw that
these files are in there and I didn't
realize he didn't see it eventually
asked me for them weeks later q is
addressing this 18 drive looks the same
to everyone in the team drive this
extremely important to make sure that
all your team members have access to all
the information they need so let's talk
a little bit more about that concretely
to ensure that everyone in the team gets
a consistent view of all the items in
there we had to make some changes to the
permission model and the organization
model so one of our notable changes is a
file can exist in either my drive or
teen drives but not both when a file is
in teen drives it's owned by the team
itself not any individual user not the
person who created the file those files
also have a very consistent location as
files in team drives could only ever
have one parent so everybody has knows
where every file is and they see all all
files in the same place to ensure that
everyone has a consistent do everyone
who's a member of the teen drive can see
all items they may not all be able to
write those items just depends on the
role and one of the things we've heard a
lot is people getting confused when
somebody deletes or move the file that's
in a shared folder and they don't
realize that somebody is using that file
and also all these other users don't
know what happened in teen drives we
made moving and deleting a lot more
restricted we created a new role called
called organizer and organizers are the
only members of a teen drive that can
actually move or delete content but
sometimes you don't want to have people
to get team drives but you still want to
give them access to individual files
within the team twice for example we
create a video demo in Kim voice when
you wanted to share with folks who want
the company we didn't want them to add
to draw a team voice they were not part
of the odium and all the internal docs
we have no relevance to them we just
want to give them access to as one file
so in addition to team drive membership
gives the concept of file access giving
users access to individual files within
the team drives without sharing anything
about the team dove itself so when
people saw the video of our demo they
saw the video but they did not see any
information about our team drive name
the people in the team drive or the team
that folder structure because none of
them was relevant to them so none of
that was shared and finally the old
drive model could get confusing when you
are collaborating on the same file and
different people I didn't hit the same
phone different folders let's say I have
this foundation in my presentation
folder and Steve
his next folder if we're sharing is next
to lay with me out is the same file in
two different places getting confused so
which one is the real one or other
duplicates or copies to make
collaboration that's confusing Kim Drive
files have exactly one parent that means
that every team that file belongs to a
single team drive and a single location
within the steam bath all these changes
change how the drive API works with teen
drives to avoid breaking applications we
took an opt-in approach that means if
you want to work with content in drive
or manage teen drives themselves you
need to make changes to your application
if you don't things your app will won't
break you just won't be able to access
that content before you begin though
beware the team drives is only available
for GP business and enterprise in order
to play with team drives learn about the
features and experiment with the API
you'll need to have a domain with either
of those additions in order to try these
features out that said the option
approach starts with including an extra
career parameter in most of your API
calls and this is appropriately named
supports team drives and you set it to
true this is an acknowledgement to us
that your application is ready to handle
some of the behavioral differences that
you'll experience with content and team
drives of course your application needs
to be able to handle those differences
and this includes things such as
response fields that aren't populated on
Team drug content the awareness of new
roles like organizer and restrictions on
operations such as setting parents you
know that you can only have one inside a
team drive if you don't set this
parameter we'll just pretend that the
file that you're asking for or any files
and team drives don't exist as you try
to get it you will get a 404 just like
any other file but you don't have access
to this of course is really just the tip
of the iceberg and a bit of an
oversimplification fortunately though
many apps won't need to do much more
than this in fact I was just playing
around with one of our sample
applications
a simple text editor that we had built a
couple years ago and literally the
changes were about three lines of code
so in that case it was very very simple
for me to support team drives for other
applications though the changes could
get complicated pretty quickly if you
deal a lot with permissions change logs
or do a lot of file organization you're
likely going to have a lot more changes
to think about we created a guide in our
documentation though that details all
the behavioral changes that you'll
experience with the drive API so you can
plan your work and assess the impact
appropriately so far we've told you love
about what we filled but you're probably
really interested in what you can do
with this building and how you can feel
it so for the team guys launch we've
work with our top partners to make sure
that Tina's API is working for them and
that their apps of supporting team
drives at launch in five partners here
with us today to tell us all about how
they've made use of the females API and
maybe share some tricks what they've
learned working with it first we have
Polly's from club migrator hi my name is
Polly's and i'm the co-founder and CTO
of cloud technology solutions and with
the developers of the cloud migrator
cloud my greater is the world's leading
migration platform to google g sweet
we've helped organizations my grades
emails calendars contacts and files to
the google GCS environment we've moved
over 5.5 million individuals and over
three petabytes of data and now we're
helping organizations move files from
system such as box Dropbox onedrive
SharePoint local file systems and even
Google Drive shared folders to team
drive we've been working with the Google
api's for many years and we've been
involved in some of the largest
migrations to date so for us like Steve
mentioned moving to teen drives was a
fairly trivial task
however I'd like to focus more on what
we've done with one of our customers
that we've helped to move to team drives
so let me introduce you to veolia veolia
is a large organization they specialize
in what water waste management and
energy services veolia have over 170,000
employees around the world 115,000 of
those have a G sweet account the only
moves to Google back in 2013 and they
have a very well-established Google
environment and ecosystem we all have
made extensive use of google drive with
over 18 million files as assured inside
their organization collaboration has
always been key to the way that we only
have work individuals get together to
form ad hoc groups growing and shrinking
as the need requires these teams have
utilized Google Drive and Google Docs
however we only have started to
experience some of the issues that who
dimensioned around file inconsistencies
and specifically off boarding users
where a manual process will have to be
performed in order to transfer ownership
of files for users who are being
afforded so the release of team drives
and the move to team drives is
absolutely critical for veolia start
working with the global is mt team of
veolia we set about implementing a team
drives pilot using the cloud migrator we
analyzed existing google shared folders
first we had to identify the most
appropriate users inside these shared
folders to make sure that they would
able to be to benefit from collaborating
inside 18 drive we then needed to get a
360 degree view of the file sharing
inside these folders we needed to make
sure that every user had the same view
of these files
of these files shares we also needed to
make sure it was there any external
sharing permissions that maybe those
didn't need to be passed over when we
lose the team drives could the users see
the same files and because when you're
using the API you're migrating or you're
focusing on a specific user you're
performing a migration as a user we need
to identify which user we need to do the
migration on behalf of because if you
perform the migration for somebody who
doesn't have access to all of the files
then we're going to miss some of that
data so again the analytics is key to
how that works so the result seamless
integration and migration with Clyde
migrator the users can now work on
existing files while still taking
advantage of team drives and while this
event is really a technology conference
it's important to understand the impact
that we can have to users under daily
lives so I'm going to leave you with a
statement from to be veolia CTR and on
why he feels team drive is so important
hey thanks and thanks for making it so
much easier to migrate to teen dress
right thank Ian next up is made come
from betta cloud if I can figure out to
make this work ok great thank you ho d
I'm very excited Viet next and to share
with you how better cloud will support
the management and adoption of team
drive for your organization better cloud
is the first-ever unified fast
management platform enabling IT to
centralize automate and govern users and
data across all of their staffs
environments let me talk a little bit
about how we do that as a SAS powered
organization grows in SAP adoption and
users manual administration for these
users inside these native admin consoles
becomes an unscalable burden for IT and
it also creates a security risk for your
organization you know better cloud
centralizes the functions available in
these disparate SAS admin consoles into
a single point of control better cloud
connects directly to your SAS
applications API and ingest information
about your organization and then we we
normalize that data and two buckets like
users and groups and data and resources
and we present those in in data grids
and reporting and alerts and insights
and we allow you to take action on those
data objects individual or one off and
of course we give you the ability to
create automated workflows to streamline
management for these staffs apps again
all from a single interface and better
cloud is is all in when it comes to
Google where the number one admin app on
the g sweet marketplace we're since our
inception over the last five years we've
served over
for excuse me we've served over 3,000
customers with 4 million users our
product is built completely on the
Google cloud platform and we integrate
with the entire G sweet stack to provide
a seamless management experience for IT
professionals so we remain fully
committed to supporting g sweet and of
course team drive so let's very quickly
talk about the problem you know we're
hearing more and more that IT
professionals are experiencing what
they've dubbed death by a thousand tabs
you know day-to-day assassin management
of simple user changes password changes
group membership updates or even the
more complex tasks like onboarding and
off boarding these tasks are manual
repetitive tedious and of course they're
prone to human error and in some cases
flow to results so with better cloud IT
admins can take action across their SAS
apps one offer in bulk and with better
cloud workflows they can easily automate
custom sequences that match their
existing manual process we've built this
using a when if an engine and let me
show you what it looks like for team
drive so here the IT admin is building
an onboarding workflow for their sales
department so when a new sales rep when
a new user is created and they're added
to the sales org unit we're going to
automate a number of onboarding related
activities for that user things like
adding them to the right groups sharing
the right calendars and of course adding
them to the sales team drive now this
completely automates the process of
onboarding a user into team drive but it
also makes sure that that user has the
access to everything they need on day
one and as you can see it's incredibly
easy to onboard your users to team drive
another thing that we see a lot team
changes now let's say we want to
automate the process of a user moving
from one team to another team in this
example the user is moving from the
sales team to the support team
and this workflow completely automates
removing them from the sales team drive
and adding them to the support team
drive in addition to this it also adds
them to support related items and
removes them from sales related items
like flat channels or slack user groups
and as you guys will see later in this
presentation flac has an amazing team
drive integration and finally these
actions can also be taken one offer in
bulk what we're looking at now is the
directory user grid and better cloud I
can filter by the sales or excuse me
filter by the department field in google
search it specifically for sales and
then via our action engine add them
directly to team drive so to summarize
better cloud empowers IT take action and
orchestrate complex processes across
your application users and data while
ensuring accuracy precision and
compliance every day thousands of
customers rely on better cloud to
centralize and data and controls surface
operational intelligence and orchestrate
complex actions across all their staffs
applications and now you can too with
team drive thank you thanks Nate to a
hot topic in cyber security is user and
entity behavior analytics to talk about
how a lock is reporting team drives and
their products is a the best from Cisco
[Applause]
alright awesome so the way we work has
changed over the past 10 years with the
advent of cloud and mobile more and more
people are not found by the four corners
of going to accompany every day and
working there so with that security has
obviously had to have to change so let's
talk a little bit about why we have is
past and fast applications more readily
available and we're going to these
applications because they enhance our
productivity they're more cost-effective
but also we have our on-premise data
moving to the public cloud critical
critical data moving to the public cloud
the second thing is with coffee shop IT
we're no longer having to you know work
in the office and log on to the VPN and
so this can be the two can leave us a
little bit more vulnerable to to attack
and companies can lack that visibility
and protection and the third thing is
with bring your own device and then
Internet of Things there's more
unmanaged devices going on your network
so with cloud lock it's it's a new new
security vector that has been
established because of these things and
so our concern now is what data is in
the cloud who is accessing it and what
are they doing with that data and kaz b
is the new security vector that's
protecting it and cloud lock has been
working with Google since 2007
protecting Google Drive environments we
protect us past the neias applications
and protect the users data and apps
within these applications so hood Ian
Steve mentioned some of the challenges
before on a visibility level and I want
to talk a little bit about some of the
challenges that we had in a security
level so what we did was we applied
cloud locks user behavior add to the
analytics to team drive and so for
simplicity's chase let's take company
ABC and their finance team so the
finance teams files our company assets
they're not personal and before the
finest teams files were attached to a
user and sharing with state was was
based on specific names which can be
prone to error another thing that
happened was getting visibility over
what content was in these files and
classifying them so files could reside
in multiple drives and you could use
cloud locks DLP policy is to to classify
them but you still had many you still
had sensitive information distributed
across many users and to get the big
picture view for for company ABC you
hadn't take the sum of all their files
and their sensitive information to get
an overview so with team drive this is
change you can you can specify a
container right you can label container
and put a put a specific sorry this one
put a specific put a specific team
around it so what we're doing now is the
finance team all they need to do is
establish a circle of trust and now the
sharing is centralized and the focus now
is to make sure that our circles trust
doesn't get violated and we can use call
lock to monitor that container so what
we're going to do is we're going to
monitor all the user activities or the
finance files and we can have a new
confidence in knowing that ABC's finance
documents are in one specific location
and what's notable here is one theater
category categorization is established
and you've established your circle of
trust you can companies can now put
sensitive information in the cloud and
have it contained and actively monitor
it so what is my
contain and visibility what does that
all mean so what we're going to do is
we're going to actively monitor the
team's activities and team drive and
then detect for non-member access we can
also detect for team drive membership
changes in case a non-member gets access
to the sensitive information and we can
see what actions they've taken on what
access they've had on top of that we can
actively receive notifications when a
violation does occur Google does a great
job with security however to be the most
secure you need to take a layered
approach and this is one additional
layer to add to your security stack I we
go next one so Google o'clock we serve
some of the Google's largest enterprise
clients and so we've had some pretty
complex use cases to work through and I
want to tell you a little bit about that
today so two examples of challenges that
we've had the first one is around the
definition of a user and so in cloud
lock when you're creating a policy
everything sort of revolves around the
user and the actions that user takes so
we had to reevaluate what an owner means
when we're looking at actions that
people are taking and what that means
for policy and for enforcement the
second challenge that we came across was
there to get a full picture view what
you'll need to do if you're you know
securing your environment if you need to
be able to look at all the team drives
within that environment and when we
first started working together there was
no way to do that it was impossible so
we work with hoodie and Steve to
actually create an administrator API so
that we could look at all team drives in
an environment so just some things to
consider when you are working with the
team drive API so security should always
be a priority however the user
experience is also very critical and
negatively impacting that user
experience
can force users and companies to seek
alternative solutions some cloud
applications make you put a proxy or a
gateway in front of the the solution in
order to protect and enhance security
and because Google takes an epi first
mentality it makes it very easy for
customers and vendors like us to work
with Google it's been great working with
the team they've been very responsive to
us and our questions around the API and
we're really excited to to release this
UV ba14 drive because our customers are
very interested in moving over to team
drive and now we're able to continue and
extend our security to to the team drive
so cloud locks cyber security cyber
security solution because it's an API
first mentality is very easy to plot to
deploy implement and it gets you up and
running within minutes to help
accelerate the use of clubs thank you so
team drives all about collaboration one
of our favorite new apps in the space
collaboration is blue maps and if Ellie
here today with us sells out there you
think enjoys I will run so my name is
Ella Mira and I am the co-founder and
CTO of loom at blue maps is the only
cooperate and social bottle recommended
by Google and it's fully integrated with
tea sweet new maps is everything you
need to go to work in one place and our
goal is to make sure that you will never
need your old intranet again blue maps
is a social mobile and smart internet to
connect and engage all employees it
brings all your internal communications
in a central hub corporate news business
applications include
dear sweet and social collaboration it's
built on top of tea sweet and integrate
with Directory groups drive gmail
calendar sites and much more and we are
proud to have a team one hundred percent
dedicated to the Google cloud platform
blue maps is now used all over the world
by Google customers want to make the
most out of g3 and especially team drive
for instance we have a customer Dolce
will be deploying Kim dries very soon
dulcia is an energy company a leader in
Europe with more than 13,000 employees
on g street we emboldened them two years
ago from their old custom-made intranet
and add to move more than 1000 pages to
loom apps and thousands of documents to
google drive and we now serve more than
10,000 pages every day for them and even
with these impressive numbers of pages
and employees do maps currently as an
eighty percent satisfaction rate on the
quality of the site however they want it
to simplify the permissions management
on the drive assets and they also wanted
to centralize the ownership of all the
files that are put on the internet and
then come team drive as a lot of Google
products drive is deeply integrated in
lieu maps and to there we are proud to
announce that the loom apps drive
features now fully support in drive from
a technical perspective the journey was
a pleasant one as the team drive team I
was motivated to make sure the API is
backward compatible and well documented
and all teams worked well together so we
only add to make our integrations can
drive aware
so a true maps we assemble a team of two
software engineers who cooperate
cooperated with the team drive experts
at Google and they remain available
twenty-four-seven and we are especially
grateful for beacon and early
involvement as well as recommended for
Jess with Tim support with Renault and
Austin the elders with documentation and
provided assistance on the few equips we
discovered with the APA so now let's
focus on how we solve our customers
issues including the algae's so first in
lieu maps we have widgets to embed and
bros team drives directly on any site so
these widgets are also used for basic
duration like uploading files creating
folders moving size and all of this in
an effort to encourage the usage of
drive all over the company next in the
search engine what we do it that we
aggregate data from the sides the user
directory events from calendar emails
from gmail and so we also plugged the
search engine it into team drives so
users can quickly find information from
all their corporate data and finally all
team communities are a perfect fit 14
drive they offer a place for our team to
share ideas best practices to manage
project and so employees can ask
questions they can share files plan
events in a dedicated and fully managed
team drive and calendar and so the team
drive is automatically accessible to all
community members and permissions are
synchronized as soon as you add the team
members in loomis and this is a big
relief for a customer dahlia as they can
now focus
collaboration and content creation well
if you want to know more about the maps
you can meet us meet with us at our
booth it's eat well at the moscone or
you can attend our customer testimonial
tomorrow with veolia at two-thirty p.m.
thank you great thanks thanks Ellie as
you can see teen drives and the drive
API is already a lot of our partners to
add a lot of valuable new services but
of course we're really excited about
stuff that we haven't even seen yet in
terms of new use cases and are really
excited to see what people come up with
yeah one of those forward-looking and
completely new years cases will be
presented you with someone someone tell
us all about it thank you thank you very
much ready so my name is philmont sahil
i'm a senior product manager at slack on
the platform team there and i'm super
excited to be here today so at slack and
to add everyone in this room kind of is
pretty aware that there's a massive
shift happening in the way that work is
happening and the way that businesses
are operating their software across the
world right people are actively moving
to the cloud where I've already moved
completely to the cloud the number of
tools that you're using and the software
using to accomplish work is expanding
every single day and companies are
trying to like react and figure out how
they're going to deal with this
explosion of tools and this
consumerization of the enterprise
software space and at slack will take a
very hard look at the shifting dynamic
and specifically how we can get groups
and teams people fluidly dynamically and
efficiently working together creating a
more transparent and at the end of the
day the most important thing is a more
powerful and a more efficient work
environment for you that people who are
actually accomplishing work and so our
mission here is to make people's working
lives simpler more pleasant and more
productive at work that is what we're
trying to do every single day at slack
and on the platform team our specific
team's goal is to combine the tools and
the software that you're using every
single day
bring them into the place that
conversations around the work that's
happening is there already and so what
that really looks like in practice means
that instead of having a context switch
between multiple accounts and multiple
tabs and multiple browser windows
multiple macs spaces and maybe even
multiple different OS types you can now
pull all of that software directly into
slack seamlessly integrating the
conversations you are already having a
with the work that you're attempting to
get done so what does that really mean
in practice say I'm a product manager
I'm having a conversation with my sales
team about a specific client wow I don't
meet with clients every single day so
maybe I don't have that context within
the conversation I can directly pull all
the information about this client who
they are who their account rep is are we
green yellow red with them what's the
kind of the next conversation we going
to have with them directly into the
conversation so I don't need to jump and
get disturbed and be pulled out of
context and multitask what if I want to
check the status of my support tickets
because my fancy standing automated
standing desk it won't go up and down
anymore how do what if I wanted to reach
out to my helpdesk team and be like hey
can we get someone to come and check
this out I can do that directly within
slack without having to go to another
system because there are enough systems
that are out there and most importantly
what I'm super excited to talk about
today is what if you wanted to share and
collaborate on the docks and sheets and
slides that you have within Google Drive
what if you wanted to do that or is it
necessary to go somewhere else to manage
those things and no we're really excited
with some of the work that we're doing
to pull all of that work directly into
slack so that we can connect the
powerhouse that really is Google Drive
would the work that is happening inside
of slack and it's the reason we're so
excited about team drives because it
takes google drive kind of beyond the
domain and creates these groups of
people who are attempting to accomplish
and move work together and more often
than not those groups of people
understand the context with which those
files need to be shared and those files
need to be discussed and so going into
that more micro view of those groups is
something that's super powerful now
slack in G sweet we've been integrated
since day one so day one slack came out
like we this has always been involved we
manage document importing indexing
search and discovery directly in the
slack simply by pasting that link in
there it automatically becomes a
discoverable
well and searchable within flac already
and but of course we're not stopping
there we have a very large partnership
with Google we have a bunch of new
things that are coming out in 2017 today
I'm going to focus just on the team
drive use case and the reason for that
is because we know at Google who takes
security probably like more close to
heart than anyone else and at slac that
when teams come together to work there's
a whole bunch of other issues that begin
to become a problem right we're talking
about permissions we're talking about
security we're talking about user
management we're talking about
contractors or freelancers who might
come and temporarily join our team these
all become massive problems and as your
company grows in scales and as you begin
to pull in customer data and PII data
all of this like the escalation policies
around all these become more important
for us to be able to manage and so
firstly just at the dr level you'll be
able to provision new slack teams and
users directly from google drive and so
what that means is your users your teams
your accounts they all get completely
synchronized between these two
disconnecting platforms making sure that
the people who are one are always
existent people are who are on the other
and so if you're already managing the
your user base through Google Drive you
won't have to involve any other software
applications to automatically pull that
into slack you could do that directly
from Google it's super amazing but if we
zoom on in on that a little bit and this
is the thing that I'm more excited to
talk about you'll now once that is done
you'll be able to connect slack channels
directly into team drives so what does I
mean members of a channel can
automatically become members of the team
drive any file that you're discussing
and sharing with your colleagues in that
channel can automatically be uploaded
into your team drive and then as people
leave either the company or the channel
or the project those files will be
maintained on that team drive so that
you can ensure that you never have any
kind of document loss now there's a lot
of like things that we're talking about
here there's Google Drive there's team
drives there's slack teams and there are
slack channels and so if we let believe
we try to like take that apart and make
this a little bit more real what does
that actually mean so I'm sure that most
people here have an HR department let's
hope and those that the HR department is
probably generally
questions about like you know what
benefits do I have what health insurance
can I like sign up for where's the
latest forum for pto days off and I'm
sure that you this HR team is constantly
being like oh where's the document
here's the document oh I actually don't
have access to that document can you
please share that document the number of
times that conversation that
back-and-forth happens in a platform
like psychos just like the micro the
second that are being wasted or just
like moments that your brain is having
to switch contacts go into this other
thing and set up the permissions to make
sure this individual can get access that
file now because we can sync the channel
directly with the team drive what it
means is we can set read-only
permissions on this team drive anyone
who accesses the channel and is
interested in benefits questions
automatically gets read-only access to
all of these files in the team drive
it'll be available in their search it'll
be available in their Google Drive UI
and then when they leave this HR
benefits channel you can assume that
they probably don't have any HR benefits
questions at the moment and so they'll
automatically be removed from the files
that they don't need to have access to
that's an interesting use case but let's
say we wanted to make this a little bit
more real now I'm sure that a lot of
companies are having really interesting
business development partnerships that
are the conversations that are happening
in fact there are probably a couple of
companies in this room today that are
having conversations with each other
about potential partnerships that's how
businesses move forward but those
partnerships conversation need to be
kept really quiet they knew we kept very
hush-hush and you want to make we have a
very strong amount of control in terms
of who has searched discovery access to
these documents and who can go and see
them as well and so let's say we're
talking about the slack and Google
partnership we could create a channel
that was specifically tied to this slack
in Google relationship we can create a
team drive where we have all of our
legal documents but also just like our
product development conversations in
that team drive and now as anyone who
joins the channel just called Google
partnerships automatically gets access
to all of those documents it will appear
within their drive UI it will appear
within their slack search and and if
they were to leave that project we can
automatically say well anything that you
worked on we want to keep that goes
documents hair we want new team members
to be able to discover those files but
you're no longer on the project so you
should
let your access should be revoked all of
that can now happen as easy as it is to
join or leave a slack channel and so
some absolutely amazing things with team
drive I guess the thing that we're
excited with not only is that team drive
has been announced but that all of those
api's around those permissions and
security settings that we would need to
be able to implement something on the
slack side Google's opened up and that
amount of control is just incredibly
powerful we have a bunch of things going
live in 2017 together we're really
excited for the team drives work
congratulations Steven hoodie for going
into GA today and thank you very much
thanks salman to recap team drives is
expanding drive with new capabilities to
better serve the needs of teams apps
that wish to use team drives do need to
make some changes and as you've seen we
have partners who've already gone
through this partner to add support for
teen drives to their products and
starting today the api's are available
for you to integrate with your products
as well yeah ESPO vaca said I mentioned
this morning the keynote there are lot
more exciting things coming to drive
today so to encourage everyone
interesting drive to also attend the
talk deserved another 120 it's called
google drive the enterprise very
alternative to unpin celsius and legacy
content management helpful it's it's
over than salon 850 big room and yeah i
think we're very exciting too if you
interesting drive
[Music]
you
[Music]